right now um but he's deciding between
these two moves and
um this move is not 100 obvious but if
he finds it he's going to win
let's look at wesley there on the camera
but he was dancing with his head
he's calculated and
look magnus is not reacting at all his
face is completely the same
okay he yeah he's trying to keep a poker
face but look we're seeing a series of
tracks
white's queen dropping back an amazing
idea look at this white's last move
bringing the queen back and now the
queen is simply going to enter the game
and checkmate
magnus carlson leaning back i think we
have to bring the players cameras up
because
this idea the queen jumping into the
game checkmate is unstoppable
black's king has no defenders it's
doomed um
the bar is saying 100 certainty that uh
wesley so will win this
yeah we're waiting for minecraft to just
give up now yeah yeah this face is
uh i mean that queen move is just
unstoppable and there's uh he missed it
and he resigns
[Laughter]
for wesley so he had to win this game to
tie
the f the first match in the final he
did it with
amazing